well let's take a look at some of the
world uh news now Ukraine's Air Force
says it carried out an air strike on the
Crimean coastal town of
Theodosia one person was reportedly
killed in the attack and two others
injured footage posted on social media
showed large explosions near the town's
Port Ukraine's Air Force Commander says
a ship belonging to a Russian fleet was
targeted local officials say the area
has been cordoned off and the fire has
been quickly
contained but more on this story Yulia
shapovalova is standing by a mosow but
first let's go to ID bake who uh is in
keev for us and uh essid can you just
give us a bit more of an idea on uh what
has happened with the strike what
exactly was it targeting and and what
sort of damage has it
caused well according to the ukrainians
they claim to have destroyed a major
major Landing ship the Novus in the port
of fedia in Russian controlled Crimea
now we understand this is a large
amphibious Landing ship we've had no
confirmation if any soldiers have been
killed in that attack now footage posted
to social media shows uh large
explosions it shows a huge Fireball
going up into the sky and this footage
was also shared by the Air Force
Commander Lieutenant General mikolai
oleschuk now it's difficult to
independent verify some of these videos
indeed some of the details of these
claims but what we can tell you is that
the Ukrainian Air Force say that on the
early hours of Tuesday morning that They
carried out a missile attack on that
Port of fed doia now this isn't the
first time Ukrainian forces have
targeted uh sites in Russian controlled
Crimea in last month and in September
and even last year they've said to have
targeted Landing ships and submarines uh
and this uh and as the war has continued
the Ukrainian uh militaries
capabilities and range of their weapons
has increased and that's thanks to
weapons supplied to them by their
Western allies but it's important to
note as this war has continued both
sides whenever they make advances or
they carry out attacks they boast about
them and they play play them up and
whenever they suffer any losses they
tend to play them down okay thanks so
much for that update that's essid bake
for us in ke well let's bring in julan
now she's live for us in Moscow and as
Ed was mentioning there this is a large
Landing warship what's been the re
action uh from the
Kremlin well yeah exactly so Russian
defense minister sir shangu has briefed
President Putin about the situation
about the Ukrainian attack on the
Crimean Port of Fe doia and the Damage
sustained by The noas Landing ship uh
the Russian side does not specify how
badly the ship was damaged we know just
an update for you one person has died
and four have been injured as a result
of the attack in fi doia we've heard
from head of Russian controlled crime
Serge Aion of reporting the attack on
the port and it took place as Assad said
in the early morning hours today
according to him um there was a
detonation in the port followed by a
fire which later was put out as the
Russian Ministry of Defense clarified uh
the Ukrainian Aviation used aircraft
guided missiles presumably these Storm
Shadow missiles while the Russian air
defense destroyed two Ukrainian uh suit
24 bombers uh that actually had launched
the missiles targeting the port of fod
doia uh the large Landing ship in
novature Cask uh was damaged as we know
as well as the maritime terminal there
and according to some Russian military
correspondents the uh Landing ship was
presumably heavy loaded with equipment
and or ammunition uh judging by the
detonation and the Ukrainian site says
it was carrying Iranian shahad drones Uh
Russian authorities also reported damage
to six other buildings nearby with
mostly shattered Windows there and now
it's planned to resettle Residence of
several houses near the emergency side
that's according to the Russian
authorities here okay thanks so much
Julia that's Julia shova for us in
Moscow